pinter très tâche est très attaché à un
pays à la famille des choses que je
prends beaucoup la vie parisienne très
peu pour lui depuis toujours c'est à
astaffort dans le village de son enfance
que francis cabrel se ressource
le natif d'agen est un artiste très
attaché à ses terres occitanes
c'est pour moi je suis né là j'ai
toujours vécu là j'ai grandi avec les
arts avec l'arrivée de là-bas dans le
lot et garonne
il est la star du village tout le monde
le connaît ses parents y habitent et sa
mère ne s'attendait pas à un tel succès
au moins ça fais comme ton du moment on
est très content très content à cabrel
n'oublie jamais d'où il vient
même quand il écume les plateaux télé
1989 il sort son septième album
sarbacane jettent un énorme succès et
l'artiste a toujours une pensée pour le
village de son enfance on dit - francis
quelques comme ça quelques questions
flash / sur ton village c'est toujours
important il n'est pas question de le
quitter
aujourd'hui c'est là que tu vas
retrouver tes amis qu'on dit tu te
ressourcer c'est même pas là que je me
ressource c'est là que je vis ils ont
cela que j'invite c'est là que j'existe
quoi en disant que paris c'est très
professionnel pour moi
en plus d'y habiter francis cabrel
participe aussi à la vie politique
d'astaffort en 1989 il devient
conseiller municipal une fonction qu'il
occupera jusqu'en 2004 ce qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est de donner mon
avis sur l'évolution de la cité roman
comment les gens
comment on peut donner plus de confort
de vie une quiétude pour la fête de la
musique
cabrel choisi aussi son village à partir
de 1988 il crée même les rencontres
d'astaffort pendant plusieurs jours des
artistes amateurs se retrouvent
partagent leur passion pour la musique
et écrivent des textes avec le chanteur
faites nous on l'accompagné des gens qui
veulent bien que les accompagnons dans
des conseils à ceux qui veulent bien
écoutez c'est pas du tout une école en
fait c'est plutôt un petit passage
pendant lequel ils sont réconfortés en
alerte
aujourd'hui francis cabrel habite
toujours astaffort il y a d'ailleurs
écrit composé et enregistré son 14e et
dernier album sorti en octobre 2001
[Musique]